i just want to have a little heart to
heart with you my heart to your heart i
am absolutely deathly afraid of cops i
will just be driving in my car and i
start having a panic attack just the
thought of a cop potentially being in
the vicinity that i'm in i'm not doing
anything wrong with as soon as i see one
i immediately think to myself i'm doing
something wrong i start sweating i start
just thinking about taking all of my
clothes off air conditioner isn't
working it's not even cooling me off is
it illegal to have my air conditioner on
high the cops just pull right up next to
me
shaking
i'm so scared i'm not even a fugitive
now if you were a cop and you pulled up
next to somebody and they looked over
and gave you that look you would
immediately think number one there's
probably something wrong with this girl
we should probably call for medical
attention or number two she's doing
something bad she's got drugs she's got
guns she's got hookers she's got
prostitutes i think those are two of the
same i'm not 100 sure they are all in my
vehicle i've got them in my trunk i've
got bodies in there i've got illegal
weapons with serial numbers filed off
i've got drugs tons and tons of drugs
got advil and benadryl and nyquil it's
all in my car i start making phone calls
of course using a headset because it's
illegal be on the phone and driving at
the same time i'm like mom you're gonna
need to bail me out of jail i start
calling my sister because my mom's like
i'm not billing about it my sister's
like um i don't even have a job i'm not
building a jail so then i called my
sister with a job oh you crazy i'm
paying my student loans basically
screwed i'm like okay if i'm going to
jail can i start a kickstarter so that i
can get out of jail can i pass go can i
collect 200 can i do something what can
i do anna at this point
i'm sitting at a red light and i realize
i'm not even
in trouble cops already gone he's long
freaking gone
until i get to my next destination and i
think that another cop is behind me i
can't even handle it i can't even handle
it i can't even imagine what it must be
like to be a real fugitive
i'm gonna go if any of you guys have
this same problem feel free to leave me
a comment below and if you don't have
that same problem you're probably a
fugitive and you're actually running for
the cops for good reasons and if you are
fugitives and you're running from the
cops
it makes me a little nervous that you're
watching my videos
feel free to subscribe and check out the
rest of my youtube channels here i love
you even if you are criminal
see ya
see you later